define una noticia que mande la línea a
en la línea b para ello elige un centro
y una razón de o botella bueno déjenme
saco mi cuadernillo
aquí tengo la gráfica vamos a elegir dos
puntos sobre la línea
para ver cómo se comportan vamos a
elegir esos dos
solo para ver qué pasa vamos a elegir un
centro de omo tencia que esté sobre la
línea que les parece esto entonces voy a
voy a realizar una potencia con centro
en el punto 02 0,2
y un factor de potencia un factor de
potencia de cuánto les gusta vamos a
decir que de 2 veamos que les pasa a
estos dos puntos pues una potencia con
factor 2 y centro en 0.2 va a alejar a
todos los puntos en un factor de 2 de
este centro así que por ejemplo este
punto este punto tiene una coordenada x
que está a cuatro unidades de la
coordenada x de 2 así que va a terminar
en un punto que está a ocho unidades de
la coordenada x2 así que terminaría en
algún punto de esta línea y la
coordenada y hay una diferencia de dos
con la coordenada del centro así que se
va a convertir en un punto que esté a
cuatro unidades en la dirección del
centro así que este punto aquí si está
en 2
terminaría por acá terminaría en este
punto aquí este punto se alejó estaba
primero a una distancia así y su
distancia al punto al centro de la
noticia se duplicó así que este punto
pasó a este punto y que de este punto
pues en la dirección x está a cuatro
unidades de el punto cero dos así que va
a terminar a ocho unidades del punto
cero dos en la dirección x y en la
dirección y está a dos unidades por lo
tanto va a terminar a cuatro unidades va
a terminar más o menos por aquí entonces
este punto vendría a dar a este punto
todo se duplicó así que sí aplicó la
potencia con un centro sobre la línea lo
que está pasando es que la línea se está
estirando contrayendo pero como una
línea tiene una longitud infinita eso no
importa entonces la línea se va a la
línea a
noten que si la línea no fuera una línea
sino sólo fuera un segmento lo que
pasaría es que el segmento se
transformaría en un segmento con la
misma pendiente pero su longitud se
alteraría por el factor noticia así que
como la línea se va en la niña
esto no me sirve esto no me sirve pero
hay muchos otros puntos en el plano y
realmente puede elegir el que yo quiera
siempre y cuando no esté entre la línea
o la línea b por ejemplo voy a elegir
este punto aquí voy a decir ahora que me
amo test ya va a tener centro centro en
el origen 100 y mi factor de potencia va
a ser pues saber este punto tiene que
llegar a este punto acá este punto hasta
una distancia de dos del origen y tiene
que llegar a una instancia de seis por
lo tanto voy a proponer que mi factor el
factor de potencia sea igual a tres y
entonces veamos qué pasa este punto está
a dos unidades en la dirección de iu con
un factor de tres termina seis unidades
por lo tanto si llega este punto acá y
este otro punto bueno no sé a dónde va a
llegar pero casi les apuesto que con
este factor este punto 4 terminaría en
12 y si prolonga esta recta si parece
ser el caso por lo tanto voy a hacer una
potencia con estas características y ver
qué pasa
bien entonces agreguemos una noticia que
va a estar centrada en el origen 0,0 y
el factor va a ser un factor de potencia
de 3
si queremos nuestra respuesta y estamos
en lo correcto